if it's basketball it's kobe's nothing
else uh that's all i wear you know he
was my idol growing up and everything
[Music]
i just got drafted to the lakers so i
had to what the kobe 6 is never would
really even wear them honestly but i
brought them out for our rookie card
photo shoot but little did i know at the
end of the photo shoot they take all of
our shoes we have to give them up they
cut them up and they put them into the
trading cards
so i was extremely upset about it
when kobe was was with adidas he had
those those moon shoes or whatever it
was the silver ones and i wanted them so
bad it was christmas and my mom she got
me the jordans that came out when he was
with the wizards and it was the suede
and had the blue strip at the bottom i
was upset
that she had got me to new jordans
because i wanted the kobe's so bad man
it was ugly shoe ever so i think that's
really what started my love for sneakers
these are these are special i was really
excited when i was able to sign with the
knicks as always a dream of mine to play
there
and these were the first shoe
that i wore my first time ever putting
on that nick uniform san antonio on the
road pulled out the undefeated kobe
because these were the first time that
he started
doing the low top shoe honestly man my
first bucket in these i don't remember
it but i remember i was so hyped up
putting on the jersey and just wanted to
play so well that like i started the
game off horrible like i couldn't make a
shot
uh and then eventually i got going uh
and i ended up having a great game
madison square is a special place and i
didn't realize the energy and how crazy
it was like i played in barclays in
college i always loved going to new york
but i didn't realize the energy and
excitement of new york knicks fans
so my first time ever playing in there
it was literally like a broadway show
like you know the whole
arena is dark the court is lit up and
the fans are going nuts and now i really
get to call that place home and on top
of that building something special there
man it's it's truly been amazing
the gold hall of fame kobe's these are
the last ones ever released of kobe shoe
with nike but i don't think i'll ever
wear uh
you know these will probably stay until
kiting gets older he loves i think
jordan ones are his most comfortable
shoe he loves the kyries so yeah uh
that's pretty much what's in his
rotation right now there's definitely a
kite in archive having another little
boy here soon so just for them to be
able to have that piece of me or all my
jerseys whatever it is kaiden and you
know a little man they can fight over it
when they get older
[Music]